tell you this on a more serious
note this is something I'm dealing with
in my life I just I recently found out
that the girl I'm dating her ex is a
Navy
SEAL that sucks it sucks dick dude
that's the worst a of all time I never
even thought it you want to feel
insecure as a man that's the wor I never
never even thought of that one as like
that could happen to me I spent my whole
life thinking black eyy worst case on
this
and by the way I mean that with all due
respect to the black community dude for
real I wish people feared my dick like
that I I wish my dick struck fear in new
entire
races nobody fears my dick
dude nobody fears my
dick other than like women in parking
garages
they you get me in a parking garage all
of a sudden my dick's top of the food
chain see me lurking behind a pillar in
there
is just with a GameStop bag
just a dude Navy
SEAL it's a tough
one I do this thing it's not a good
thing but whenever whenever I'm dating a
girl I always talk [__] on her
ex's it's not a good look women don't
respect it kind of makes me look like a
[__] I like it
I can't stop doing and normally it's
easy normally it's like what's your ex
do he's a [__] substitute teacher
it's weird he wants to hang out with
kids like that bad you know
like this one's tough this is a tough X
to make fun of just want to walk around
the apartment all day
just [__] Navy
Seals they're kind of [__] if you
really think about it you know what I
mean like using night vision sneaking up
on guys that's a [__] coward's way to
fight
dude you know who's actually Brave
Al-Qaeda
that that takes courage and
bravery pajamas throwing rocks at
tanks heroic [__] dude just you and your
boys going out in flipflops you're all
going to get [__]
up no
training zero military training dude
those guys those dudes they had [__]
they had one set of monkey bars that's
what they all trained
on and they were proud of the monkey
bars you remember that video you've seen
them using the monkey bars they were
they they filmed themselves using the
monkey bars and then sent that tape out
to the world like not
bad a buddy of mine watches like uh like
death videos on the internet
I
don't he watches
them we're hanging out I'll watch we
watch them I Fu I was over at his place
we were watching I don't know if you
noticed the war in the Middle East is
just on the internet the whole [__]
every dude out there on both sides was
wearing GoPros the entire time like you
can watch it we watched like three hours
of the war in Iraq and after the first
hour I found myself starting to cheer
not cheer but
like relate I felt like I could relate
more to the monkey bars guys you know
what I mean they were a little more my
speed you ever wonder how you would do
out there watch those guys those are
just normal [__] dudes second shots
are fired there's no game plan there oh
[__] very relatable guns jamming try to
fire a rocket it goes straight [__]
backwards they're very they look like me
trying to fire a gun their feet move
when they
shoot very relatable they also never won
they never they got [__] up every
single time bad they would blow up like
one truck every five months they'd be
just as surprised as everybody [__]
finally worked out you could hear in
their voice someone blow up they' be
like oh I it's like yeah dude that's a
human reaction that's relatable that's
what I would do if I saw a [__]
explosion I go
oh that's human you ever watch us kill
people I can't relate to that at all
there's some black Hawk helicopter with
night vision Ms down like 40 people
pilot gets on he just goes clear just F
just flies away it's like yo that's a
psycho that guy didn't give a [__] about
that at least Isis is down there having
fun dancing
afterwards you know it's like Ewok
village down there
you also I'm not I'm not actually Pro
Isis all right it's just a Navy SEAL did
[__] my
girlfriend and I am having a pretty
tough time dealing with
that it sucks
dude can't get it out of my
head some [__] cool jacked
hero just getting tactical on my sweet
baby's
[__] just clearing out every corner of
my sweet Angel's body
just checking behind every door in there
just clear go red team
Advance now I'm in there
[Applause]
[__] F I know we're laughing and
having a good time but for real that
does suck that suck that absolutely
sucks
sexually sexually I have I have to
follow a [__] Navy
SEAL they never quit until the job's
done dude that's their whole thing I
quit a lot all right the job's done when
I'm tired which is usually pretty early
into the
mission my arms start shaking pretty
early they give out next thing you know
we're having belly-to-belly
missionary just hunched over breathing
in her ear like a pug for 5
minutes
just
coughing coughing during sex is funny
[Applause]
just you guys know belly to belly
missionary dude don't [__] I saw this
crowd dude I see you boy loud of belly
belly tonight dude this guy's hunched
over you don't even think about that
noise you're making in that poor woman's
ear every woman in this room has heard
that
noise you've never thought the only way
I can describe it is like you ever lay
down and a dog starts sniffing your ear
that's what it sounds like
[Applause]
[Laughter]
every hard to walk away and leave it
like that can we give it one more night
just one more
night and you never say what you want me
bab no my girlfriend and I we have sex
and it's
fine it's okay one thing that's funny
about though is uh it's a new enough
relationship that my girlfriend's still
allowed during
sex you remember that you remember that
phase it's still new enough in the
relationship that my girlfriend like
screams every time we have sex and and
I'm just up there like yeah
right yeah right lady I've seen women
walk through this no
problem I mean it's nice it's a nice
gesture sometimes it tricks me some like
yeah
yeah yeah maybe it's not going to
fit no it's going to
fit it's going toit it's going to fall
out a couple
times no the screaming the screaming
phase is about done we moved in together
so that's when that that's when that
ends once you before you live together
sex is like [__]
me once you move in together sex slowly
becomes just some lady laying on a bed
next to a pile of unfolded laundry
just ow you're on my
hair no we live together now my
girlfriend moved in with me so we have
sex and uh as soon as we're on having
sex I wish that she would [__]
evaporate PL
it no all would no you guys are right I
hate playing Xbox by myself dude the
[__] I love having her around all the
time [__] turning on
lights asking me to hang out
no no we hang out I'm just not used to
it I'm not used to I'm nice used to
hanging out with a woman all the time
I'm nice to hanging out with women I
don't have any female friends I'm more
of a having a good time type of
guy I don't even know what women do for
fun just [__] fold [__] or something
like
that
huh look I know that's not the best joke
of all time from your seats that's not
the most well-crafted joke what do women
do fold
[__] but from up here from up here it's
a it's a very very funny joke I get to
say something as dumb as what do women
do fold [__] and then look out and see
about 15 different women
going I understand most of the women
here are girlfriends that were dragged
to this show that already don't really
like me cuz every time they're in their
car their boyfriend's like bab listen to
this part of the
podcast yeah I'm
aware oh